Well, welcome everybody to another holistic health our zoom call
But we have a number of questions that we want to get over that you guys said didn't so thank you for setting those in so let's jump right to the questions
That's a counters I have
Autoimmune Lyme disease. I have always felt with
A lot of urinary tract infections and I felt I've had a lot of urinary I remember I've just copied and pasted your questions here
So a lot of UTIs throughout this after a plenty of water. You can't use
The cranzile products from the clinic. Those are the US enzyme cranzile is a product for UTIs
Because of the high oxlates. I seem to be getting these infections almost weekly
So one of the reasons that cranberry helps with UTI is it helps to
acidify the urine and make a core environment for urinary tract infections
That can be helpful
so
Even with the high oxlates. I would still try it make sure you don't have a reaction just go slow
There's also several other products that we have in the store UTI synergy
I think that is a designs for health product that works real well
So there are a number of other products that you can try for UTIs
The other thing is okay, so we finished question so I could answer it better
I just purchased the rife machine from the clinic and I'm waiting for it to come. Could you speak to why so many UTIs?
When I
Drink close to why I have so many UTIs when I drink close to a gallon of water a day
How often would you use the rife machine for this issue?
So you if you have the rife machine at home
It's a great tool for biotoxins. So the rife is best utilized to
help kill living organisms
So with Lyme disease. So I program your rife when I sent it out and I put Candida programs in there as you requested and
There's a bunch of urinary tract infection programs that are shorter anywhere we do 20 minutes a day or an hour to half a day
And I would use those as often as you are sitting down. So I would set up the rife in a place where
Typically at your bedside and set up your bedroom so that you can
Utilize it during the day when you maybe you have a habit of I like to sit and read a book
For about an hour every day or I like to sit and watch TV before I go to bed
Well, that's where you could run the UTI programs put the ball right down by your bladder
So it's as close to your kidneys your urine or your bladder as possible
And it can be very effective for UTIs
I would not stop like I said before trying some of the other products that are on the market
Yes, sometimes people get UTIs because they are
dehydrated and they have they don't have a good flow through their kidneys
But remember you the possibility exists that a person can drink actually too much water that you're flushing out your electrolytes
And your urine is not doesn't have that acidity to help kill infection
So try back you know off on the water. I just have to I try some things
One at a time so you know what's working or not working that one I'd give it a couple weeks
Uh, I'm dealing with mast cell issues doing a good diet and using is to clear
Uh, concerned about getting rid of mold and heavy metals. I'm
Really not sure what binders to use. I have no gallbladder. I have autoimmune Lyman would like to use the right machine
So uh, mast cell issues. What are mast cell issues? So your mast cells
Create your immediate immune response
Histamine and a number of other chemicals are produced in a mast cell response
It's to elicit in a immune response
cytokines and chemokines are two types of chemical reactions that take place or released by the mast cell in order to attract in immune response
Now the problem is is that we can end up with a hyper mast cell response and we have all these
inflammatory chemicals
That I just mentioned and then you have this inflammation of the tissues
So why do people get mast cell
hyper mast cell? We should actually say because I'm your mast cells are supposed to do this
Why do you get overproduction by the mast cells? Well
Can be
Probably the most common reason is over exposure of things in our environment. So sometimes that have been causing that our viruses
um the whole
Corona virus issue
Because it was I believe
Labyrinatory made virus. It was it was upregulated to produce more of a response in the body
Was causing a hyper mast cell response in a lot of people
um when a person is exposed to a lot of toxins they can develop this
And then your mast cells can change your receptors on your mast cells can actually increase in a person can be prone to a
hyper mast cell response
That could be a real issue. So
histoclear
So understand the different histamine products that are out there. So a mast cell response happens in the tissues
So let's is in your let's say in your cytosis or in your
In your arm and you get a rash on your arms hyper mast cell response, right?
um
The then what would you do to reduce that mast cell response?
Well, I would use products um like our products like clear histamine
scavenger
That is a product that would reduce histamines in the tissue
Another one is our as our product called that chiro
Clear hiss now there there's those are two different products with completely different
um
Nutrients in them that some people do better with one and some people do better
With the other so I would try out those that's those are to reduce
histamine in the tissue
Then you both of those products I think have corset in but a person could take corset in a person could even use some of the
Flaminolates like a resveratrol
Uh and curcumin and white willow bark
uh and
uh
you know
Stinging nettles things like that you could try some of those things
But these products have been formulated specifically for
histamine in the tissue the clear histamine scavenger and the natural clear hiss
We actually have a child version of the natural clear hiss called clear hiss junior
Um, that's for removing histamine in the tissue when you look at your genes
That's typically your h-n-m-t gene defect not so much your d-a-o gene defect
It's a little technical
But your product that you're using you're using hista clear
hista clear is the d-a-o enzyme that's made by the d-a-o gene
And that's typically really working in the gut
So when you take d-a-o enzyme there's other companies that make d-a-o enzyme
That's our private label
hista clear is the d-a-o enzyme that's reducing histamine in the intestinal tract
If you're not really absorbing that at all
It's not gonna decrease histamine in the tissue
Except it will decrease the histamine in your gut so you'll have less absorption
So that's not a mass cell problem though
So if you have hyperabsorption of histamines because of damaged gut
Because of food sensitivity so you're producing extra inflammation of the gut
That's a different problem than a mass cell hyperactivation syndrome
So a mass cell hyperactivation is because
That's what's going on in the tissue really completely
Separate from the gut
So hista clear should be taken with food
Well, you could take it without food too because it will clean up the gut
But definitely if you're eating food that has high histamine you should take hista clear
The negative about hista clear is that it's a more expensive product
So unless it's a specific gut issue that you really want to calm down
I'd say start with the other products
Concert about getting rid of mold so having mold and heavy metals is another reason why a person
Could have mass cell activation
Remember I said it could be because of toxins well mold and mycotoxins from mold
As well as heavy metals and pesticides and herbicides and things like that can cause
Mass cell activation as well as adjuvox and vaccines as well as anything that you're exposed to could increase mass cell activation
I'm not really sure what binders to you so binders
This is really a totally different question because binders have to do with binding things in the gut
It doesn't binders don't have anything to do. It's really getting rid of stuff in the tissues
By definition of binders is that you're really not absorbing it. You're using a binder to grab onto things in the gut
The my favorite binder is the clear binder
But if you're taking fiber
That's a binder
Just you can't go wrong with different binders that are on the market
There's a lot of good binders on the market clear binder is a really good binder
That's our private label, but we have multiple different binders in our store
You can't go wrong with any of them. You really can't overtake binders. You can't hurt yourself with binders
You're not really absorbing binders. You just could be wasting money by taking too many
But you can't hurt yourself by taking too many binders
For the most part
But it really has nothing to do with whether you have a gallbladder or not
So binders aren't to grab onto toxins that your liver's getting rid of
And binders will help calm down any autoimmune disease because they do help calm down the inflammatory process in the gut
Regardless if it's from live or anything else
Are the supplements suggested from the defective genes?
So this person had a genetic review with us and
We made recommendations for different supplements
So this person asks are they determined by kinesiology? No
The supplements from your genetic review are based upon the defects in your gene pathways are not based upon kinesiology
So also how do these supplements include suggestions affect the defective pathway?
Well, they're supporting it
So just because a person has gene defects doesn't mean that that gene pathway is like working horribly
It suggests that there's going to be issues that you have the
High probability of having issues of that pathway and here's the suggestions
So that's what we make the suggestions
In your genetic review based upon that pathway
You may not need it. So let's let's say let's pretend somebody has
Huge issues with their let's go back to genetic the the histamine pathway
So let's say they have defects in their DAO and their HNMT genes
And I mean there are a whole bunch of twos in there so you have twos and wugs
Wugs are a single allele defect, twos are a double allele defect
More of a problem have a greater chance of
Having an issue with that pathway and let's say it's really horrible
And I've talked to people it's just like oh my gosh look at all the twos you got
Oh, you must really have histamine issues and they're like uh, no
I don't have any histamine issues
And they really don't and I dig into a lot of people don't understand that
It could be inflamed inflammation in your gut could be you know, don't understand what it is
Well, let's say they did and they're not really having problems with it
Maybe you don't need to even take those things
But you have to the benefit of doing a genetic workup is that you get an idea of what
This could be a problem in the future
Maybe I shouldn't be careful of consuming too many histamines or maybe I should
You know just just be aware of that so I you know look for food sensitivities and things and try to clean up my diet
You could help prevent a lot of things
So
Answering this question do these supplements and food
Suggestions effective effective pathway. Yes. They support that effective pathway
Will they at some point not be defective?
No, no, you cannot there's practitioners out there that say yes, you're going to take this thing and you're going to change your genes
Okay, show me the proof because there isn't it, you know, it's easy to prove
Let's run your genetics. Then you take their special supplements and then you run your genetics again
If you don't have any defects, I've never ever ever ever seen that you're not going to change that gene
Um, you're not going to change your genes
The only thing that you're going to change your genes is you could it could become worse
If you're exposed to toxins or exposed to poisons that damages your genes
That's the problem with this whole stupid hemorrhoid
Immortate vaccine. It was actually dead. It's actually damages people's genes
And you end up with defects in different gene pathways that you'd ever had and you will pass them on to your children if you are still having babies
So horrible horrible horrible um played with people's genes
Um, and they exposed why do we have defects at our genes? Well some defects are good to have
Some defects most are not good to have so um and
It's because we're exposed to poisons and toxins
And our maybe we weren't but our parents were now. We inherited their genes
um
Guarantee you though I could never prove this effect if we were able to go back in time and measure your great great great great grandfather's genes
They would look all way better than yours and um
But when your grandfather was exposed to poisons because you know they spread DDT in the street
Then she had your mother um and passed on the defects that she ended up developing from exposure to those poisons
Now your mother inherited those defects even though she may never have been exposed to DDT
But now she's got defects in her surgical P450 pathway or pine pathway
And now you passed she passed them on to you and you're exposed to a roundup and even have more defects in the site
P450 pathway and now you had babies and passed them on to your babies and they have more issues
With exposure to roundup than you ever did because they have more defects
That's how it works. Can you get away with that? Can you get it? Can you fix that? Can you correct those defects?
No, you can't
But they're not correct
You're the right frequencies affect the genes by bringing the body and balance
Well, they can help support those defects made of what you're running
But they're not going to fix your genes. They're not going to be fixed
So it's I think it's a very valuable to run a genetic profile
Even if you're not having issues with something you could learn how to best support it and to protect yourself
And it just brings to mind
You know some things like okay
Well, I guess you know
I'm still wanting to have children and you know
I want to pass on good genes to my kid
So I'm going to start cleaning up my diet and take care of myself and clean up my exposure to things
Helps us remember those things
Okay, thank you everybody
Remember to send in your questions into the questions section on the
Course that you
Have subscribed to
And we'll get to your questions
We're fully as we get in and data to quit by questions
And I'll have to pick and choose where right now where I'm going to get to everybody's questions
All right with that I'll say goodbye. No, I'm praying for you guys and I love you all and um
I wish you the best
Bye bye